talk to me about nofap the online space
has got this different perception of
what it is a lot of people think like
the levitation and it's going to make
you amazing and everything and so when
you go from this like multiple times a
day to like once every three days you're
masturbating it's quite a big difference
it's called online which you're telling
you if you fap again you've lost the
benefits because that's so unhealthy to
tell young guys I've come across more
young men who have been pained by nofa
than who have just like got problems
with me and masturbation they get like
this existential crisis where now they
feel like more of a loser because they
keep failing no fact I was asking the
question like where did you start
jacking off and they'll say age 13
they're 19 right now six years you're
building up this habit you just think
you're gonna break the Habit just like
that with a lot of the things we do that
we don't like ourselves for doing less
than 50 of the problem is the actual
activity that you do most of the problem
comes from the story that you tell
yourself about the type of person you
are for having done that action a lot of
the benefits from going through any type
of personal development comes from a
reframing around capturing our own
agency to do with that particular action
very well said